so I'm here on vacation and I'm in full
hustle mode in the Berkshires with Lizzy
and Misha and the clients having great
time but many of you been asking me what
I'm doing with this video game thing I'm
up to interesting side project that will
be coming out early next year right now
what I'm trying to do is amass as many
toys from the sixties seventies eighties
early nineties even end video games I
really honestly anything like retro
anything that was collected outside like
baseball cards that really heavy into
like Thundercats WWF My Little Pony
Strawberry Shortcake and I'm feeling
this huge energy I'm getting a lot of
emails I've been going back and forth
and I'm loving it this whole bar door
energy out you know what I'm talking
about like that old days when you train
it a kangaroo Junior for like something
else so I'm really looking to barter
with you guys I've got lots of stuff
I've got money I've got wine
I've got other collectible stuff I've
got me I've got books I've got
connections though I won't sell out a
lot of people have been asking me to
tweet about their stuff I can't do that
um but just look at a barter I am
looking for a ton of stuff 60 70 80s 90s
collectible toy nostalgic type stuff
what are you looking for hit me up Gary
at vaynermedia calm I love the quiche
the next couple days when we should
sleeping like now I could pull off some
gangster deals to 3:00 in the morning
look at us on my vacation I'm looking
for 60s and 70s ladies toys